but a story that's less often remarked
on is the vast infrastructure of timing
that had to be built across the globe in
order to measure and then distribute the
precise time that sailors needed in
order to set their chronometers right
during long voyages
but i think infrastructure is pretty
important too which is why i spend so
much time studying it and exploring it
the time bowl set up at the greenwich
observatory in 1833
to transmit time to sailors waiting in
the river thames below is fairly well
known
but the same year
out of sight of the british imperial
capital
another time bowl was erected by the
british government that one was on the
coast of southern africa at the cape of
good hope
before too long it was joined by
literally hundreds of time signaling
structures
acting as frontier foot soldiers around
the coastlines of all empires
and let me be clear about the scale of
this infrastructure of time in 1908 the
british navy carried out a survey that
listed a total of 200 time signals
that could be found on coastlines or in
ports around the world
there are usually time balls like the
one at greenwich or built for a very
different reason the one in new york's
times square
but sometimes they took the form of
timed disks or time guns or time
signaling flags
200 of them and the document reveals the
astonishing geographical reach of the
world's maritime powers
it was by far the world's biggest
network of time signaling stations
but by 1908 the year the survey was
published america was fast catching up
as a world power having built 22 coastal
time signals on its own soil with a
further two in its porch possessions in
the philippines each and every one of
these time signal installations was a
major undertaking involving complex
surveying engineering land acquisition
the recruitment and management of labor
forces
legal negotiation maintenance
astronomical observation instrument
making
and a huge amount of expertise developed
over decades or centuries
each one was a heavy investment and a
long-term liability and taken together
with the tens of thousands of shipboard
chronometers for which they were built
and the global network of chronometer
testing stations chronometer and clock
makers retailers supply depots
not to mention the dozens of government
astronomical observatories that found
the time in the first place to
distribute across this network
we can see a vast global physical
presence of time of clocks in one form
or another that's been all but forgotten
plot all these time signals and
chronometers on a map of the world and
you can see how clocks enabled empires